[Musique]
on
20 août lever du soleil 6h50 coucher
d'inter 58
14h08 de lumière ma vie baissent de jour
en jour mais au papier monsieur
j'apprends énormément à ce poste parce
que tu m'as vautours sais j'ai eu une
première fois très très tôt non non non
maintenant on met du coup je peux
comprendre que ton et on dit on a des
nouveaux seins des nouvelles fait ça
vous met tout vols concernent art
[Applaudissements]
haweij kutwa bientôt tu verras plus très
bien quand tu auras peu de lumière la
nuit quand l'espace est mal éclairé par
exemple et puis tu vas perdre la vue
bientôt on va pas les laisser gâcher vos
vacances ça on les emmerde
[Musique]
je pensais y être préparés mais ça m'a
fait un choc est ce que mes rêves vont
disparaître aussi
[Musique]
ça va ma chérie tu passes un bel été je
traite sur le plus beau que ta vie
[Musique]
holmes 2 août il envisage incroyable je
serais mort de ne pas l'avoir vu
alors je veux le voir encore je veux le
sauver je veux être sauvé
en bas